welcome back everybody
just do a quick sound check
okay thank you thank you for your
patience everybody I'm afraid we lost
the sound on on that before
so we're now moving on to item seven
which is a forthcoming decisions list
um does anybody have any comments on the
on the decisions list
okay in which case item eight MCA slash
22 41 is the general fund budget for
23.24 and the four-year outlook for
23.24
um with the supporting we've got Melissa
Evans the director of corporate
resources and also Rebecca Hewitt the
assistant manager and financial
accountant and I'm going to ask Council
Whitehead as the cabinet member for
finance to introduce this report
thank you
thank you madam chairman for my first
report today I'd like to introduce a
general fund budget 2324 and four-year
Outlook report which starts on page 13
of our cabinet pack
introducing this report I'm going to
approach it on the basis that the
evolving budget has already been to
Cabinet briefings to various political
group briefings to an all member
briefing it's also twice being in the
public domain before coming before
overview and scrutiny committee first in
November to discuss this underlying
assumptions and then in January we
presented the numbers for the 20 24 in
more detail
so instead of once again flagging a lot
of detail that can be read in today's
report I just want to concentrate on a
few key issues
as we approach the end of this current
Administration the 2324 budget taken
with a four-year Outlook in front of
cabinet today covers the whole period by
a month and a few days of the next
Administration
actress have not been too melodramatic
when I therefore say that this report in
looking to the Future sets out this
cabinet's financial Legacy to the next
Administration
crucial set of data that I consider the
most vital when considering an
appraising the budget only emerges from
some of the final numbers produced by
the finance team and I'm referring to
the four-year outlook on medium-term
projections
and I use the word crucial and vital
because delivery of the council's
mission its vision and its strategies
are all based on the long-term
sustainability of the council's finances
so any proposal to freeze our council
tax precept must only be evaluated and
decided in the context of our
medium-term objections and we can see
these projections in table eight and all
the various assumptions built into the
projections are set out in paragraphs
4.38 to 4.45 in the report
and over that four-year period we're
forecasting a cumulative surplus of 5
million
now a deficit in the year 2627 did give
me some cause to pause
but cabinet should note that these
projections assume no replacement for no
new house bonus Beyond 24.25 and that's
despite new homes bonus being crucial
income for most Borough and District
councils
so there will surely be something to all
councils from central government to take
its place
the projections also assume no growth in
business rates despite the significant
growth that will have inevitably come
through from Gateway 14 as well as from
elsewhere in the district
the projections soon no further increase
in fees and charges Beyond those
proposed next year
yet an additional increase in fees and
charges of two and a half percent each
year were just on its own eliminate that
fourth year deficit and would actually
add 800 000 to accumulated Surplus
so whilst proposing a council tax free
for 23 24 and possibly Beyond even in
these inflationary times we can
objectively demonstrate that our
medium-term finances will be secure and
healthy
and must also mention our reserves
position and some proposed changes to
take changes to them we're going forward
when the council commenced the
development to Gateway 14 it did so by
lending money to Gateway 14 limited the
Holy House of Sydney company which we
set up to deliver this ambitious project
the castle charged interest on the loan
but the interest wasn't paid to the
council but rather it accumulated
onto the outstanding debt in accounting
terms the interest was accrued as there
was no immediate cash flow
and given the inherent risks in this
large project turning 168 Acres of
agricultural land into a business park
the section 151 officer myself set up a
reserve equivalent to the accrued
interest
but the sale of the land to the range
and December 22 has the risk project
crude interest has been paid and so the
reserve which we call the commercial
development risk management Reserve can
now be repurposed
so what we are proposing is to combine
that with our growth and efficiency
Reserve along with any anticipated 20 to
23 Surplus into one new large strategic
transformation and infrastructure fund
and that should be well in excess of 8
million at the start of the next
financial year
this is the Legacy with which to fund
future investment in transformation and
infrastructure
we also as a matter of prudence will
increase our general fund Reserve to 10
of the net budget as explained in
paragraph 4.6
and the full extent of all our reserves
is set out in table five
finally our Capital program forms a part
of the ongoing investment in the future
of our Council
to the anticipated carry forward from 20
to 23 of 19.229 million we are proposing
to add a further 7.1 million in 2324
the details of this plus a third
three-year Capital projection
is set out by project and by service
area isn't shown in appendix a
so if cabinet or other members present
have any questions on the reporters
presented today I'll be happy to answer
them and they call on the members of our
final Steve present to help me with the
extensive finder detail but first let's
remove the recommendations 3.1 and 3.2
in the report that is that cabinet
endorse a general fund budget proposals
23 24 and the four-year Outlook and that
next year's general fund budget will be
based on no increase to the present band
the council tax 171 pounds 59.
thank you madam chair
councilor Whitehead do we have a second
councilor Richardson
thank you very much chair um and very
happy to Second uh this paper I would
just add a brief comment to welcome the
fact that yet again uh we have another
year where we are projecting a healthy
budget surplus which enables us once
again to freeze council tax council tax
for our residents but crucially as
councilor Whitehead mentioned this
proposed budget also means that we can
continue to invest significant sums of
money in our communities and across the
district as a whole
one item on the agenda this uh this
morning is a perfect example of that
um but we should obviously in in
reviewing this paper and hopefully
approving it
um must obviously remember and take into
consideration we have a very
advantageous position as it as a
district council one that isn't shared
by many other local authorities so I
entirely agree with councilor
Whitehead's comments that this
represents
um reflects a very strong financial
Legacy and so I'm very happy to check
into the recommendations Chad thank you
thank you counselor Jason do we have any
questions from cabinet members
any questions from anybody else
councilor Miller
two or three questions if I may
um
the first one refers to table two
um on page six of the report
where we've got the the budget changes
and the general fund and there's a line
second one down short-term borrowing
higher interest rates on 50 million
that's three and a half percent
um forgive me if I got this wrong I'm
assuming that 50 million is the the
money we borrowed for cifco
I think we've always been told in the
past that that money is borrowed at a
fixed rate so I'm not sure I fully
understand why there's a change or an
increasing costs there
you want to do the questions one at a
time at least it's probably more helpful
for me actually yes sure I was just
going to write them all down but uh
table table two let's have a look um
second line down shot to borrows higher
interest rates 50 million at 3.5 percent
I mean certainly the short-term
borrowing rates have gone up uh recently
from those ridiculously 11 figures about
point five percent to you know four
percent going forward but I just ask as
Melissa just to confirm whether it's
tied up with it because that person not
sure it is
um yeah I can confirm that the
cwe pwlb fixed rate so the rest of it
will be in short-term borrowing so
you've only got an element of it which
is fixed rates pwlb which is the 18
million the rest of it is short term so
that's why some of that not all of that
is linked to cifco the rest of it is
linked to your Capital program as well
so it's not all attractable to zip code
um then thanks for that clarification
um
4.31 in the report says that the council
should avoid using reserves to meet
regular recurring Financial commitments
which you know that's that's a general
principle
um I think common to all councils
um but this sort of touches on what the
point that councilor Willem is making
earlier why is it that we're not
um
taking our Council of locality Awards
out of you know in the main budget
rather than out of a reserve because
that would seem to contradict our our
policy here and then 4.32
the money that's mentioned there is the
locality funding part of this figure
um
the
if if we put in extra money for
Community grants slash localities
funding
um
crucial thing will be that that will
need to be ring fenced in next uh es
budget so it won't won't be a reserve as
such
for that future year but I say it will
be shown as a separate line item
so what was your second question again
three two yeah it is locality
funding which I think is only about 250k
over the year is that part of the the
sums in that
that um paragraph
I don't think so but again I'll just
asked me listen to confirm
thank you
okay it's within there thank
you and the last one is about the risk
management
um
uh 10.1 the table there
um the first line in that table
we may be unable to react in a timely
and effective way to financial demands
and then it has likelihood of three
probable an impact for disaster is that
really our situation it seems quite a
prismic sort of analysis of the risk I'm
not sure it really is that high
I suppose
you know that description we may be
unable to react in a timely and
effective way to financial demands I
guess it's it's it would be the Quantum
of those financial demands that would
define it I can assume that um we're
talking there I mean for example was it
two or three years ago when covered
first hit and the first projections I
saw from Finance team was that it was
going to cost the council about four
million pounds and I think at the time
we had about four million pound of
Reserves at the efficiency fund I mean I
think we could have just about coped
there but something like that four
million is would be a
what the government sets in and helped
all councils thank goodness including
ourselves but the I think it just
depends on the sort of quantum of the
facial demands that are upcoming but I
certainly take your point that it just
seems
quite drastic
um it would only be a disaster in in an
extreme I suppose
thank you
yes as you say we've gone through this
several times so finding
interesting questions is getting more
difficult perhaps that's a good thing
um
and just to return to Amana a comment if
I'm on that risk you know clearly
clearly the the impact of the this is it
will be the impact is disaster but the
probability is pretty low the question
really is are looking at
um the medium-term predictions and I was
particularly looking at Power 439
uh
it it's a
it looks as though we were again
predicting that it's great at the moment
but in about three years time disaster
will strike and it mentions the
estimated tax growth over the period to
only covers 17 of the increases in costs
that are anticipating and mentions the
things in your own as well as we we lose
I was wandering against that how
we're really Justified not putting up
council tax which is the thing in
general I would support but the issue
seems to be that um in much of the way
as we argue in the in the housing budget
that if we don't put the tax up then the
the base shrinks the money we don't gain
this year is carried on forward as far
as you care to mention into the future
so are we generating
um potential disaster for uh for a new
Administration
um well obviously
um you've heard your question in advance
and I I'd rather hope that
um my solution speech did address quite
a few of those concerns because I said
there's a there's five million acute
cumulative Surplus over those four years
but as you point out it um and as I
noticed immediately they uh it was
declining particularly towards I mean I
would say the third year is effectively
a sort of break-even position the fourth
year is a deficit of um 400 odd thousand
that's on 352 000 but um
I feel that um there's so much Prudence
built into
um in into the four-year projections
um I say I can't believe that the
government won't need to step in and
find some replacement for new homes
bonus just because 70 of the councils
desperately need that to balance their
budgets I can't believe there'll be no
growth in business rates knowing what's
going on Gateway 14.
I can't believe it won't increase our
fees and charges although they're not
built in Beyond increases Beyond next
year
and
I think
I think as well there's no moment we're
forecasting in there no Castle tax
increase for the next four years I would
be the golf smart to be honest if that
would be the situation that um
fine for next year but I think we need
to take one year at a time because we do
budget one year at a time we can we're
not begging into
into stone this um this four-year
projection it's just there to give us
the comfort that um we are okay and I
think the five million surplus we are
counselor
Lee and there was one another question
uh but but obviously you you signed the
introduction to your report that we're
trying not to be as pessimistic
and to an extent not taking into account
the various increases you'll clearly
expect over the next few years to my
view is still being pessimistic my
second question really was around the um
the impact on the housing revenue
account the cross charge to that seems
to be increasing and I was just really
questioning is that really necessary and
based in in clear need
because clearly that other account is or
we are told is in Greater difficulties
than this one
thank you
um yes without preempting my
introduction to the HRA which is in a
quite a different situation to the
general fund uh budget
they we are very conscious as a cabinet
that we're trying to help the HRA in any
way we can but at the same time from an
accounting point of view from an audit
point of view from a strict ring fencing
point of view they have to be seen to be
squeaky clean in terms of how we
allocate costs between the general fund
and the HRA and the results of being
squeaky clean and complying with the
regulations is the recharge that's in
front of us but be happy for Melissa to
add anything if she wanted to
I think
good morning
um so so we are currently
um seeking some legal advice um around
this subject particularly around Grounds
Maintenance and whether we deem
um the the
you know housing land
um land which is used for
um all the public and not just
um tenants and when we've received that
in information we will then take you as
to whether we can make some changes in
the way
um that that apportionment is made
thank you is that likely to occur before
the budget is finally set
no unfortunately not
thank you chair I've got two questions
they are they are
lit our last and I'll ask them both at
once so to speak
um
uh it's clear that the cabinet's aim of
the last four years seems to have been
for financial savings so were directors
asked to put forward proposals and
projects for developing services for our
residents
the impression I get from councilor
Whitehead's introduction is that making
savings is more important than providing
improved services to our tenants and
other residents
so I invite him to comment on this is
they're not scope
to encourage directors to propose new
and improved services and the Staffing
needed to deliver them
foreign
thank you
um well
perhaps you have missed
um understood what you know the whole
principle behind
um what I'm talking about savings I mean
we are continuously striving to um
for efficiency Savings in other words
you know getting more bang for our
bucket As Americans might say but that
that's that you know efficiency and
um delivering
um and as best as best as we can it's
quite different to I think to making
savings for savings sake and of course I
think um
I think you are possibly guilty of um
ignoring the fact that you know we put
these five million pound plus pops aside
and I think they covered about 50 odd
projects these are all projects that we
were able to to finance sometimes as
Pilots sometimes as longer term projects
um to to improve things for residents so
um
and I think um our track record shows
that rather than looking for savings we
look for efficiencies and from those
efficiencies we then make sure that we
do our best for our residents
I I would like to see more evidence of
those five million the pots being being
or the expenditure of them being planned
uh
rather than a planned spend rather than
just ad hoc
um fairly small projects
um on the whole
um if I could just come back on your um
councilor Whitehead statement we want
more more
or is it more more bang for our budget
well hey yes yeah but we've got the
budget we've got the money let's get
more not really not
not keep looking for
happy with efficiency savings but we
seem to we seem to be in this position
uh that we're trying to save money left
right and Center rather than to get more
for for the money that we have got
um
so can I I've got to ask a question so
can I be assured that we're going to
look to get more for the budget rather
than to to shape it off the budget
yes I mean the hope is that we will
shortly be emerging from both the
current cost of living crisis and you
know Peak interest rates we will we're
coming into a post-covered environment
because let's not forget what last two
or three years have actually been like
and hopefully these green sunlight
Uplands that are ahead of us combined
with the sort of budget surpluses that
we we see in our finances
we can do what we all want to do as
counselors which is to deliver for our
residents
I think on on somewhat inclined to
disagree with councilman in as much as
in in as much as
we are
really careful
with our residents money
there is always a better faster cheaper
more efficient way of doing stuff and
that is the best way to save our
residents money so cutting down on
printing paper
for me was a no-brainer working smarter
our officers go out with laptops or
iPads or smartphones in order to engage
with our residents and that all means
that we work much much smarter and our
officers can then spend the time in
dealing with the more complicated
personal issues that our residents
struggle with you know most most of our
residents are quite happy to self-serve
and access our services that way and
that gives our officers far more time
and scope to deal with more sensitive
issues that are really really
complicated and so
it's entirely right that we look to work
in a much smarter way and so I make no
apologies for that that's how we're
going to carry on working
has to be the way forward
Council Whitehead
perhaps we're still on questions and
answers yeah well just
so wanting to you know perhaps fill in
on the answer that to the question that
Council elements quite rightly asked and
um you know going forward as well it's
not just day-to-day stuff that we need
to be
working on but we've got so much bigger
Ambitions I mean you know we'd like
we're delivering on the Gateway 14
project but um for our residents as well
we've got this the Shelf project and
we've got the Innovation and skill
center coming up as potential projects
you know we were able to put aside the
money for the um AV bus project which
we're going to talk about shortly as
well all these sort of things are are
over and above it's like the day-to-day
um
delivery of our services but it's still
vital
and can only come from good finances
field
we'll do a really simple one suggest we
look at page 37 chart 8.
consider whether it's accurate
it's obviously a
something intended to show to a wider
audience at some time
I think the bit of the coin that says 4p
is shown as something larger than the
piece of coin that shows 13p so it's
probably giving the wrong message to
whoever it goes to
sorry what was your question
the answer is
it's the first time we've brought it
forward and the reality is it as it's
shown at the moment is not accurate
because it does look like the parish
slice for example is bigger than the PCC
slice despite one being 13p and one
being 4p and I've been insured well I
raised the question myself an email over
the weekend I've been assured that when
it comes to full Council
that coin will be split into the correct
pie slices
foreign
questions oh sorry councilor Richardson
thank you chair um it was actually just
a technical question for clarity which I
think I might need to ask of officers is
just going back to council Fields first
question on table 10.1 for risk
management can I just check
um for the scoring that's in here is
that pre-mitigation uh risk scoring or
is it post-mitigation risk scoring
because I think that distinction could
be quite useful when we are assessing in
in this um
precisely the scale of the rest that
we're looking at
um obviously we do have mitigations in
place which is the reserves
um that we've got set aside but I think
I would be
I would rather leave it where it is just
for the the stuff that councilor White
had described it just in case you know
things did go terribly wrong that
actually we've got our eye on that risk
and we're not saying we're going to
ignore it because actually if we were in
a covered situation again it could
potentially be a disaster so we have got
mitigations in place but this is just
with a nod to the just in case if you
like I think it's prudent just to keep
that in there and keep our eye on it
thank you
thank you so if we've got no more
questions I'm going to open it up for
debate does any cabinet wish to stop
councilor Richardson
uh thank you very much chair I was going
to um just make a couple of points
expanding in fact on what you've said
and what councilor Whitehead said in
response to councilor willem's question
um and I I alluded to this in in my um
in my comments when seconding but I will
just expand on them a little bit further
because I think in this instance what we
need to remember is that the
efficiencies that you've we've just been
discussing and referring to are the key
enablers for some of the key
transformation work that we want to do
as a council and I've alluded to the
fact as councilor Whitehead has already
said we've got The Stone Market health
education Leisure facility on the agenda
today we've also got the skills and
Innovation Center Gateway 14 as well as
uh as councilor Whitehead has said which
are not insignificant sums of money and
it's the efficiencies and the careful
management of the council's finances
that have enabled us to to make those
Investments but I take it I do accept
obviously that there is a distinction
between our Capital spend and increasing
the services we provide to our residents
and I'm sure if Council Fatman were here
she would make this point as well which
is that through over the course of the
last four years we've also implemented a
new well-being strategy the first
well-being strategy a new sport Leisure
and physical activity strategy and there
are several outputs of those things like
social describing the um holiday
activity and food program where we have
increased the support we provide to
Residents saying nothing about the cost
and the work that we put in to our
communities during the course of the
pandemic so to characterize the last
four years as being a purely Financial
saving driven prioritization I think is
is totally false
um I'm so I'm very pleased that this
budget has gone forward that we have put
forward and are proposing strong
investment in two quite significant
projects and one of which I'll be
referring to later so
I'm I'm very content that we've actually
done an awful lot to support our
communities and so I'm we'll be voting
for this budget thank you Jeff
thank you
I think it's also worth noting that the
the projects that we spoke about as part
of our 5.1 million initiatives
um we are looking at those to see
whether any of those can be carried over
in the long term
into our base budget and we will be
looking at some of those to see how
they've been performing and measuring
the outcomes from those
so there's no more debate so the
recommendations are that the general
fund budget proposals for 23.24 and the
four-year Outlook set out in the report
be endorsed for recommendation to
Council on the 23rd of February
and that the general fund budget for
2324 is based on zero percent increase
in the band D council tax I'm now going
to ask the governance officer to conduct
the vote
thank you chair the vote is in progress
cancer Fleming
thank you my vote is four thank you
counselor headingham
that is six votes for chair that's
unanimous
thank you moving on now to item nine
this is MCA slash 22 42 and is the
housing revenue account 2324 budget
um and we've still got Melissa Evans a
corporate director for court
director for corporate resources
um and Rebecca Hewitt the assistant
manager and financial accountant and
we've also joined by Dire Robinson
[Music]
Deborah sorry
I've got myself in the muddle there
we're joined by Deborah Fenton
director of Housing and Jenny Smith is
the financial business partner and I'm
going to ask councilor Whitehead once
again to introduce this report
yes thank you madam chairman so yes and
I'd like to introduce the second budget
report which covers the ring fenced HRA
housing revenue account
so our council's vision is for our
residents living affordable and high
quality homes that enable them to build
settled safe and healthy lives
that's both a noble and an attainable
Vision but we should also acknowledge
that it's also a challenging Vision to
deliver
this time last year I reported out the
previous two years during the covered
pandemic and negatively impacted our
housing revenue account
lockdown measures and social distancing
had seriously affected our maintenance
repair program and it had seriously
delayed our new bill program
and since then increased inflationary
pressures the cost of living crisis and
material supply issues have created
further significant headwinds
in December 22 I gave an update on the
current years for Casa HRA which showed
an adverse variance of 770 000. we wait
a further update to that forecast which
will come to cabinet in the next meeting
in March yeah these are certainly
challenging times
so this HRA budget today is one a
one-year interim budget which shows an
in-year deficit of 442 000.
with our HR reserves forecast to be
around 6.3 million at the start of the
new year we can handle such annual
deficits in the short term but they are
clearly not sustainable over a much
extended time period
therefore before this calendar year 2023
ends members can expect revised and
updated 30-year HRA business plan
setting out a clear pathway to a
position of long-term sustainability
that will deliver our council's home and
housing strategy and will deliver our
council's vision for our tenants
table one in the report sets out under
12 separate headings of various cost
pressures that we are facing and they
total
3.684 million
set against that we have savings and a
traditional income a total 3.147 million
so but that leaves a net increase of 537
compared to the budget we set last year
members will see we have some
significant Revenue increases proposed
for the year and that clearly set out
within the recommendations in section
three of the report
now the government shied away from its
policy of the last three years which
allowed rent increases of CPI plus one
percent
and that's perhaps not surprisingly with
CPI reaching double-digit levels
recently so the government's decided to
mandate a rent cap increase for 23 24 of
7 percent
within the report we modeled scenarios
based on Lower increases of three and
five percent and they're shown in table
four
but the hit to our HRA from those lower
rent increases would be significant
these lower rent increases were
dramatically add to the challenge we
already face in getting our HRA back to
long-term sustainability
our officers recommend we go for the
seven percent rent increase and I
believe that will be the general
approach to council housing rents across
the country
that increases below the current level
of inflation
and it's below the level of benefit
uplifts that are coming through this
coming April so I therefore concur with
that recommendation and indeed the other
recommended increases set out in section
three
and I trust the cabinet will endorse
those today as the recommendations to
take forward to full Council on the 23rd
of February
so let me let me end this intuitary
speech by formally proposing those
recommendations in sections three of the
report
could I invite the current member for
housing to Second them thank you
and second it yeah
thank you councilor headingham
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
any questions from anybody else
councilor field
yes at the risk of asking questions I've
asked before
um
the increasing seven percentage of
sheltered housing service charges
and on top of that an increase of
whatever it is 27 plus
pounds per month on on Heating and water
seems high for a group of individuals
that are
at the lower end of income scalables
are into our Egypt pensions probably
when they were
in employment I just wondering if
bearing in mind the things you said
about increasing efficiency in the main
budget which is completely something
wrong with the plan to do they know
efficiencies you can gain in this
particular budget which would allow us
to um
Forest element of our society somewhat
more
sympathetically I'll use that word
it does seem to me that they're they're
heavy increases
thank you
thank you for your question
um yeah the ring thanks to HRA account
includes both sort of General dwellings
castle house dwellings as well as
sheltered housing dwellings
and I think it's important which is
possible that we
clearly Define what the what you know
what the various expenses relating to
shelter housing are
sure that there is no cross subsidy
between General Council housing and
sheltered Housing Services I know it's
an exercise that um the housing team
have been looking at to try and
break down almost by um
I sheltered housing
sites rather than more generally and of
course our new director of housing has
only been imposed fairly recently but I
suspect she's probably itching to to to
answer your question a bit herself as
well so I'm gonna hand out to Deborah
for her thoughts on your question
challenging for for
um all our tenants not just those in
sheltered housing
um however we have got a higher
proportion of residents in sheltered
housing that are on housing benefit and
it was for that reason
um that government actually said we
could increase sheltered housing rent by
10.1 percent however we did recognize
the the pressure on all our tenants
um those in general need and sheltered
housing and restricted it at the um
seven percent
um I think it's worth pointing out also
that we have
um a significant challenge ahead of us
with the HRA in that we have
um a number of properties that we need
to get up to EPC level C and we need to
put a significant amount of capital
investment in to bring our properties up
to a standard where
um you know they they can keep their
homes heated
so I would say it's a very fine
Balancing Act
however if we are going to make the
commitment to provide safe warm dry
homes
we do have to increase both our rents
and our service charges to ensure we've
got the capital investment in the future
to provide great homes for our people
thank you
councilor Willem
thank you chair
um a question about the grassed areas
around our what were formerly Council of
the state I know in in some Villages
there were a development of say 30 or 40
and now sort of 90 sold off
um are we still paying for those grassed
areas out of
um the HRA account
um will it be possible to look at
other than being maintained out of the
general fund or or indeed handed over to
local councils
and the second question is something
completely different
it's to do with table three and it
states that you've taken account of
voids and I'd ask is one percent avoids
realistic what void time does that
represent
and can that be reduced
bearing in mind if we can halve the time
to return avoid an empty house into use
we can halve the loss on the rental
income shown in table three
yeah that's it
thank you
um yeah I mean for example in my own
Ward there's a um
you know a large
state which
some stage I guess back before 1980 was
present Council owned and now I think it
gets down to probably about seven or
eight houses out of 40 odd and it's got
a lot of common area a big green in the
middle and um it's um
and
um
you know bad people there's a wider
benefit than just the few Council
tenants that remain there but again if I
might just um as Deborah for a focus on
that
foreign
it's likely that it's that it is still
HRA London if it's still HRA land then
we will be maintaining that land
um in partnership with Mark's team
um Grounds Maintenance
um we could potentially have this
local councils about whether they wish
to take on the ownership of that land
um you know and that that's a debate to
be had
um
I'm just moving on to the the void
question in indeed if we could reduce
the the void time that would absolutely
uh reduce the time that the property is
empty and increase uh the income
and we are working on developing a
scheme at the moment where we
um
put in a minimum standard in which
properties should be returned to us and
what I mean by that is not allowing
properties to be returned so this is for
people who are transferring if there has
been willful damage and neglect
um however this is something which is
still being prepared and will of course
um come to ons for for some debate
um that would decrease the amount of
time the property is void but would also
substantially decrease the amount of
work which is required in a void so
therefore twofold would be saving time
and cost for the HRA so
um as I said that that's been worked on
at the moment as a proposal and we hope
to bring that in later on this year
thank you could I just ask one
straightforward question
um in terms of who maintains these
grassed areas
is the child might the transfer of the
land to some other Council or some other
um say to public realm is that the
difficulty is it not easy to transfer a
piece of housing land that with no
tenants around it
um are you stuck with it basically
um it's not easy because there is a cost
attached to the land
um in terms of one being the value but I
suppose that isn't specifically the the
issue the issue is is that land will
need to be maintained and if you're
transferring that land to a parish then
the parish have then got to pay to
maintain that land
um the the and the other issue is is you
know we've got to be confident that when
we do transfer that land it will be kept
in good order
um at you know for the local residents
so so that so that's the challenge but
it's not it's not insurmountable we can
have those conversations
thank you everybody so I'm now going to
open it up for debate does anybody wish
to discuss this
okay so the recommendations are
that the HRA budget proposals for 23 24
set out in the report the endorse for
recommendation to Council on the 23rd of
February
it's an increase of seven percent for
Council house rents
equivalent to an average rent increase
of six pounds 16 Pence for social rent
and nine pound zero three Pence for
affordable rent a week be implemented
that CPI increase of 10.1 percent in
garage rents equivalent to an average
rent increase of four pound 86 Pence or
for four pound 91 Pence for private
rental a month to be implemented
that an increase of seven percent for
sheltered housing service charges
equivalent to 10 pound 83 a month be
implemented
there's an increase for sheltered
housing utility charges equivalent to 27
pound 93 Pence a month
uh with 30 for heating and 62 for water
be implemented
and that in principle right to buy
receipts should be retained to enable
continued development and acquisition of
new Council buildings
and I'm now going to ask the officer to
conduct the vote
that vote is now
known for
please thank you chair that is six foot
four that's unanimous
thank you very much so item 10 is MCA
slash 22-43 is the business rates relief
policies
and supporting us today we've got
Melissa Evans the director of corporate
resources and also Andrew Wilcock who's
the SRP operations manager
and I'm going to invite councilor
Whitehead to introduce introduce this
report
thank you madam chairman sir for my
third and final report today I'd like to
give a brief introduction to the report
on these two new business right relief
policies
so the government's recently announced
these two new relief policies as part of
the Autumn statement and they are the
business rate
retail hospitality and Leisure relief
scheme
which I'm going to refer to as the rhl
and a new supporting small businesses
release scheme which I refer to as the
SSB
the government expects a water level
sorry the government expects local
authorities such as use our
discretionary relief powers to Grant to
Grant these new rhl and SSB release
these discretionary policies are drawn
at buyer officers based on the criteria
outlined in the government guidance
government will now will then fully
compensate the local Authority for the
total amount of Revenue lost through the
granting of these schemes and it does
this via section 31 payments
so these release cost us nothing but
obviously our local business rate payers
and the local economy benefit from the
release
the rhl scheme increased the level of
relief to those covered by the policy
from the current level of 50 to 75 for
the new year and that's up to 110 000
pound per business
the SSB scheme caps business rate
increases to those small businesses that
are losing eligibility of seeing a
reduction in small business rate relief
or rural rate relief 600 pound per year
from the start of the new year
and these release need to be applied to
the bills of eligible rate payers that
are going out in early March hence the
urgency to approve today these
discretionary schemes
the policies themselves are attached to
our reporters appendix sale appendix B
I'm just relieved that we have within
our finance and shared revenues
partnership team staff that are
experienced in working what seems to be
an Ever more complex Business rating
environment
now make relief that I no longer as an
accountant in business face the task of
budgeting ahead for business rate
reliability to me the whole Business
rating scheme desperately needs
simplifying
if members have any query on how these
release schemes apply or the details
contained within the covering appendices
that are pleased to say that Andrew
Wilcock the SRP operations manager is on
hand today to handle those queries
however before inviting any questions
from cabinet or members present I first
like to move the recommendations set out
in section three would ask for a second
there thank you
thank you Council wanted do we have a
second to councilor Richardson
thanks very much Chad um yes more than
happy to Second uh the recommendations
in in this paper
um I think this is an excellent policy
um I think I'm I agree entirely with all
of the underlying assumptions that
Council Whitehead mentioned uh I think
this is reasonably speaking a pretty
obvious decision for us and we'll
definitely be supporting local
businesses and local and the local
economy during what is obviously a very
challenging time
um so as I say more than happy to
support this and we'll be voting in
favor of it thank you thank you
councilor Richardson do we have any
questions from cabinet
questions from anybody else
does anybody wish to debate this item
Okay so
the recommendations are the cabinet
approves the introduction of the
discretionary retail hospitality and
Leisure and supporting small business
rate relief policies are set out in
appendix one and two for the 23-24
financial year
and that cabinet gives authority to the
director for corporate resources in
consultation with a Cabinet member for
finance to agree future changes to this
discretionary retail hospitality and
Leisure and supporting small business
rate relief policies for the life of the
2023 rating list
the officer to conduct the vote
okay chair the vote is now
important councilor Fleming mayor take
your vote please it's four please thank
you
thank you chair that is six votes for
that's unanimous
thank you very much
thank you officers
item 11 is MCA slash
22-44 is the mid-suffolk district
council ring funding for electric bus
rural transport
we've got to with us
Fiona Duhamel the director for economic
growth and climate change and also
Catherine Davis who's our sustainable
travel officer
and I'm going to invite the council
Cabinet member for economy to introduce
this report it is it is down for being
introduced by the cabinet member for
communities but unfortunately she's
poorly today so councilor Richardson is
stepping into the breach
thank you councilor Richard
thank you very much chair as you say I'm
introducing the paper the ring fenced
funding for electric busfield transport
on behalf of councilor flattman as
members may recall this project arose
from a budget amendment tabled at our
full council meeting in February of last
year and officers have since conducted a
comprehensive research and evidence
Gathering exercise along with the
detailed options appraisal
during that period a dedicated
cross-party member working group has met
on numerous occasions to consider this
evidence review options and provide a
state on the development of the scheme
to date the details of which are
included within this report I would like
to thank officers present for their
support in developing this work to date
which has been significant as I hope you
can see from the detail within this
paper
as you might be able to infer from
recommendation 3.3 the overarching
preference of the working group was to
link this scheme to the travel plan
required as a planning condition for
Gateway 14.
however as you will see from the
evidence base contained within the
report most comparable schemes in
existence are still within their pilot
or testing phase and there remains
significant uncertainty around their
longer term Financial sustainability
with this in mind and in the context of
the travel plan being developed for
Gateway 14 and the working group's views
on that the recommendation is for this
report to be paused while more data can
be collected to better understand the
commitments that the council may wish or
choose to enter into
as a council we are of course committed
to promoting strong sustainable
travelings across our district through
initiatives such as our local cycling
and walking infrastructure plan but it
is a recommendation of the working group
that it would not be financially sound
for this project to be progressed while
there are still outstanding concerns
about the viability of such a scheme to
that end I'm happy to propose the
recommendations this will be paused
while further Evidence can be gathered
in support of this project however I
would like to amend the recommendations
slightly from the report itself
upon reflection we feel that delegation
is would not be appropriate and any
future decision be brought back to
Cabinet before proceeding so I'm
removing recommendation 3.3 and
including at the end of recommendation
3.2 the words accepting the further
agreement with Gateway 14 board may be
required if the finance if the final
scheme is linked to Gateway 14 delivery
that amended recommendation is in the
modern.gov app and so with that I would
ask for a second
thank you Chad
thank you councilor Richardson do we
have a secondary councilor Whitehead
yes I'm more than happy to Second those
revised recommendations and having
spoken so much already today I'm not
going to say very much more but I
certainly want to acknowledge the
phenomenal amount of effort that
officers and particularly Catherine
Davis have put into the uh
to investigating schemes both
sort of locally in Suffolk and really
across the whole United Kingdom
it's quite Apparent from the attached
appendix and all the details in there
which um
a great deal of reading within there for
for members to look at that um the
so much work has been gone into it and
um it may seem a shame that um we have
let's come to a conclusion in our
pausing this but I think we really are
in front of um
Cutting Edge technology and um
someone I'm trying to think it was
something at the weekend said that they
prefer to be to to get it get something
right then let's try to be the first
first leaders in these things and I
think it's important as a district
council that that would we do the same
so I'm happy to Second the
recommendations thank you
thank you very much
do we have any questions from cabinet
thank you chair this is a question
around the time scale for the travel
plan with Gateway 14. first I'd like to
recognize all the work carried out by
Catherine and others we I was a member
of the working group we had a phenomenal
amount of information given to us
um uh and I recognize that we're not
going to be buying a minibus in there in
the near future however I believe the
time scale for the travel plan for
Gateway 14. I mean they're they're now
sort of starting to develop that
um and I was speaking to her so
Christopher Hayworth
um at the road opening and he agreed
it's now the appropriate time for
discussions with workmen who will be the
Gateway 14 management contractor
um because with lead-in times for
um acquiring electric mini buses those
those discussions need to start now what
would it would be unfortunate if they
came up with a proposal which made it
difficult for uh other local services to
be incorporated now is the time to to
start to negotiate and see what can be
done with staff on the site working
three shift part there's going to be
periods of time when there will be uh
availability so can I ask question
Council yeah so I have asked a question
I'm just about to repeat the question
um Are the officers aware of the time
scale for the Gateway 14 travel plan and
will will they seek to discuss that with
uh the management contractor
thank you chair thank you councilor
William for that question I'll defer to
officers in in a second just to confirm
my understanding is that the travel plan
is required by the planning condition to
be completed prior to the operations
commencing at the range I believe that's
the case but I'll hand over to officers
and ditto
the I think there's
a couple of just general points about
um engaging with uh
leading time
um may be quite extensive for an
electric uh minibus obviously I think
what needs to happen now is for that
further Evidence base to be collated
that data to be reviewed and then
obviously there'll need to be a decision
a political decision about whether that
is what we want to pursue in relation to
Gateway 14 or if there's another model
so I think it's important that we have
that decision confirmed before we
advance too far into negotiations but
happy to for office to just clarify if
if I've got that first point right thank
you Chen
thank you yeah
um yes the travel plan related to
Gateway 14 is linked to the occupation
by the range and that is due in about
summer 2024 so we are aware of the
timeline um and yes we will keep on
discussing
um with colleagues that the opportunity
around this and Gateway 14.
thank you councilman
um a couple of questions the first one
um
clearly the initial agreement on this
project was something that came from a
full council meeting
and so I just asked the question should
it not be a full Council decision
whether or not to pause the project and
I've got a couple of other questions as
well
as a matter of the question my
understanding is the
um full text of the report that would
have gone to Cabinet sorry to full
Council in February of last year would
have included language that expressed
the delegation of it to uh for to
Cabinet to implement and so it's that
for that reason it's a cabinet decision
whether or not to proceed rather than a
full Council decision but I may choose
to defer to the either chief executive
or to the acting monitoring officer for
this meeting to just confirm whether
that is the case from a Governor's
perspective
thank you chair just to confirm it is an
executive or cabinet decision
um that will be made to to go ahead the
decision at Council was really around
the feasibility of it so it's a cabinet
decision
um so um a couple of further questions
then
um
firstly what is the lead time for
ordering an electric bus if anyone knows
that I'd be I'd be interested to know
uh and secondly uh we the recommendation
is to pause the delivery but we don't it
doesn't say for how long
thank you very much Chad um I'll answer
both of those but I'm going to have to
defer to officers for their expert
advice Minds in answer to the first
question I'm not aware of a particular
lead time my suspicion is it would be uh
variable depending on the model chosen
um in terms of pause delivery I think
we've left that as a deliberate decision
to not attach time scale to it for two
reasons the first being there are
several different initiatives ongoing
and I think it might be a little bit
arbitrary to say We'll pause it for this
month this number of months and then
make a decision then it could be that
over the course of the remains of this
year there are other schemes which as
they start to complete their pilot phase
uh produce evidence that gives us more
of a steer in One Direction or another
and secondly I suspect given we're not
that far away from from the election
period it may be for the new
Administration and and well either it
might be myself or it could be other
portfolio holders to consider that uh as
and when because this would be a major
commitment for us and I don't think in
the final few months of a certainly
perspective if we're talking
something of this Sky size and scale I
think it would be appropriate for a new
Administration to make that decision and
that commitment
sorry chair could I just go to offices
to clarify
um I think I haven't got a lot to add
really only to say that um
we're pausing a decision but actually
officers will continue to monitor the
situation and do work on on this
including those discussions with Gateway
14 so so it's not the officer is going
to walk away from it for the next
goodness knows how long we will continue
to monitor that situation and work with
stakeholders and potential partners
thank you councilman Yeah final question
and certainly acknowledge that the hard
work that's gone into this project
um I wasn't on the working group um was
this the unanimous recommendation of the
group to pause it um or where there's a
was there a difference of views within
the group
thank you uh chair I believe it was
unanimous I I think that there was some
degree of disappointment of frustration
felt
um that we weren't able to progress to a
decision but there certainly weren't any
strong objections that I can record it
wasn't a minuted discussion
um but that I think was
the general consensus based on the
evidence that was presented in front of
us
thank you Council
[Music]
or thank you
the figures on which air
compose was based I suppose I'll have a
couple of questions
um perhaps the first one might be that
[Music]
um
we talk about Gateway 14 there are
clearly other
circumstances there are other
developments for instance Port one in
great Logan where they're also putting
in
electric mini buses to to run people in
from the adjacent
areas Ipswich and
parishes so the question really is are
we just focusing on Gateway 14 you know
our own development or would the focus
be wider coming in perhaps things like
the developments in Elms well as well
so a more General attempt to address an
issue we know the economy is is lacking
workers or so they claim at the moment
and clearly getting such people to to a
job is a benefit a wider benefit and
my mighty managing so
that that's the first question are we
considering other areas or we just my
own quickly focused on Gateway 14 which
doesn't come to fruition for a while
whereas the other developments are
clearly uh actually up and operational
now
thank you uh casterfield for that
question so the short answer is the uh
the working group was presented with a
variety of options and asked to get a
steer on those and as I referred to in
my introduction the general preference
of the working group was to focus on
Gateway 14 because there was the most
obvious and immediate demand in the form
of that travel plan that was a planning
condition of the range
um occupying the site which as as you've
heard earlier is is during the summer of
next year so is it too far away in terms
of as we conducted or reviewed the
options presented in front of us one
thing that I think we were conscious of
is not wishing to duplicate the role of
things like Sil and section 106 in
securing infrastructure for particularly
residential development that exists
within the district
um I I don't think that was the
intention behind this budget proposal
that's certainly what not how it's
worded and I think over the course of
the meetings which have taken place over
the last six months and the general view
was that the Gateway 14 option presented
the most value for money if we were to
pursue it but obviously as you've heard
the evidence-based just and the data
there just is not strong enough to
support the viability of such a scheme
as it currently exists but that may
that measures some of these other
comparable schemes uh finish their pilot
phases
thank you I wasn't aware that seal could
be used for Revenue funding but there
you go
um
the next question perhaps really being
that uh
we
you you clearly are looking for a viable
scheme and I was going to point out that
is the question is really is that a
sensible thing to be doing clearly
things are Transport for London are not
viable in the sense that they have a
revenue which covers their cost they are
perhaps viable if you consider a wider
um
influence that they do provide a means
for people who don't have cars to get to
to get to to jobs and those jobs are
necessary and at the moment tend to be
in Industries with large vacancies so
are we narrowly focusing our ideas of
viability on simply does the revenue
cover the current running costs or do we
have a wider concept of that
thank you chair um if I just clarify the
response I gave previously yes my
understanding is it still can't be used
for Revenue
um costs but I think the point was
around uh
uh funding arising from those
developments such as section 106 being
the primary Port of Call for
infrastructure associated with that
development and on the second point I I
do think from the view of the working
group
um was very much that until we have
sufficient evidence to say one way or
another how viable this scheme would be
we wouldn't be in a position to proceed
I think the key distinction between the
between ourselves and the example you
gave of Transport for London is that
obviously we're not a statutory
transport provider so whereas tfl can
rely on the government to provide the
excess funding that it requires for us
as a district council that costs would
be incurred solely by us
um so it's I don't think it's a simple
question of whether or not the revenues
uh would meet the cost I think there's a
wider consideration about exactly what
those costs might look like over how
long and whether there's sufficient
demand to to make that sustainable for
us and viable
um but I appreciate the question of
liability May differ from one person's
perspective to the next but until we
have that broader evidence base I don't
think we're in a position to make that
judgment
it currently stands
thank you the final question perhaps
I'm sure our
proposals was for a scheduled service
based on the thought that many demand
responsive Services have blatantly
firewood and there didn't seem to be a
lot of point in traveling in that
direction and I said that I appreciate
that is a form of demand responsive
service functions and that's taxes I
think they've proceeded by Handsome cabs
a few hundred years or so ago so the
clearly is a form of demand responsive
transport that can work and it tends to
be based on a single vehicle single
driver single client model whereas you
see these buses implies multiple clients
for a single vehicle so I wonder why
they grew focused entirely on demand
responsive transport
foreign
well we started off very much
looking at sort of schedule the schedule
type services but that is as the
complexities of that for a district
council
um sort of came to the fourth the across
the whole Spectrum on that working party
the discussions then seemed to move more
towards on-demand type
um responses and then as some of the
issues with um
things like the apps and the and the way
that works we've sort of move even
closer to what seemed to be drawing ever
closer to basically a taxi type service
and and perhaps went from a minibus down
to a sort of a SUV and and Beyond so it
we must have talked for about another
six hours or probably more than that
over the across the working party and
um it just naturally evolved from
schedule to demand to almost a sort of
taxi service and I just like to add that
um you know accepting that Amendment uh
the instruction gave to officers was to
bring forward a business and social
value case and the you know the finance
and the social value you know to me
we've given equal priority but because
of the lack of um
pilot cases elsewhere there really
wasn't that sort of feedback to to
produce what we'd really hope for
thank you there are Parish councils in
all the Essex so our funding scheduled
services but I guess we wait for a new
Administration thank you
thank you very much everybody
do you wish to debate this item
councilor Fleming
yes thank you um I'd just like to add
um really my um thanks and appreciation
to officers for the immense amount of
very relevant work that has been
produced as part of our papers and um
you know I think it's absolutely right
to put this forward and we're not ready
to commit these sort of funds to a very
particular type of vehicle and um and
area we need to explore further both the
um the operating model the financial
case and the technology all these three
things are not
um as our officers are saying they're
not ready for such a large commitment of
public money I feel that would be
irresponsible there are I'm sure better
ways to provide sustainable transport to
rural areas than than we've we've you
know
found to date based on in the models
we've looked at for instance I think we
need to widen our our perspective when
this is looked at again into the
possibility of leasing a vehicle rather
than buying one I think we need to look
at the fuel types at the currently
electric minivans get about
100 or so mile range and that I know is
promotes some range anxiety especially
if things go wrong and you have to be
diverted or the weather is particularly
bad
I'd like us to to look at using possibly
hvo which is suggested in fact in our
papers or something that that could be
viable hvo incidentally doesn't contain
palm oil
um
and I think the whole thing could be
taken forward in the future in in a much
better way that provides real access to
transport for rural areas and I agree
not just in the area around stone Market
this needs to be taken out to areas such
as eye elmswell
areas where transport options just
simply aren't available for people
that's what I'd like to see simple
models that are cost effective make
environmental sense and can you know
Serve the People effectively in
mid-suffolk
thank you councilor Fleming
so the
recommendations are amended so
recommendation 3.3 is removed
recommendation 3.1 Remains the Same
which is that Council notes the
extensive work undertaken by officers to
date to consider the viability of an
electric electric bus rural transport
scheme across the district
recommendation 3.2 is amended to be to
approve the officer recommendations to
pause the delivery of this project in
order to allow more time to collate
evidence to support the viability of a
pilot scheme as limited evidence of
successful schemes has been available to
date across the local area and across
the UK
accepting that further agreement with
Gateway 14 board may be required if the
final scheme is linked to Gateway 14
delivery
so I'm now going to ask the officers to
conduct the vote thank you
it's out the vote is in progress
Ive
with the Amendments thank you
thank you thank you chair that is six
months four that is unanimous
item 12.
MCA slash 22-45
is Holmes England compliance audit for
the need a market Middle School site
and we've got with us Holly Brett who's
the corporate manager for the council's
companies and I'm going to invite
councilor headingham the council the
cabinet member for housing to introduce
this report thank you
thank you very much
performs part of a homes England audit
requirement
in 2016 the council awarded a total of
just over 1.4 million pounds Grant from
Holmes England towards the Redevelopment
of the former Middle School site in
Needham Market this enabled the public
to build 41 much needed affordable homes
for the district
the Final Phase of these lovely new
homes is nearing completion and their
first residents have moved in
part of the conditions of receiving the
grant monies is to have an audit carried
out and and for the results of that
audit to be formally reported to cabinet
newspaper does that and notes that an
Amber rating was returned the only audit
item picked up was that the valuation of
the site was just out of date from when
the site was
purchased in 2016 from the County
Council processes have been amended to
make sure this doesn't occur in the
future the cabinet is asked to formally
acknowledge the compliance or what it
received from Holmes England as per the
recommendation in the report thank you
very much
thank you Council for headingham and I'm
happy to Second this report
um do we have any questions from cabinet
do we have any questions from anybody
else
does anybody wish to debate this item
okay so the recommendation is that
mid-suffolk District Council cabinet
formally acknowledge the compliance
audit received from homes England in
relation to the affordable housing
development need a market middle school
and I'm now going to ask the officers to
conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair the vote is in progress
Council Fleming mayor take your vote
please four please thank you
thank you thank you chair that is six
foot that is unanimous
thank you very much
item 13. MCA slash 22 slash 46 is The
Stone Market health education and
Leisure facilities
known as shelf update we have with us
the director of corporate resources
sorry
director of economic growth and climate
change Fiona Duhamel and also Kate
parnam who's the project regeneration
manager
now this report contains appendices and
if members wish to question and debate
the appendices we will have to go into
closed session before the debate
and the vote will then be taken in Open
Session
so I'm going to invite the cabinet
member for economy to introduce this
report thank you
thank you very much chair I'm delighted
to introduce paper MCA slash 22-46 at
The Stone Market health education and
Leisure facilities update and to propose
the recommendations in this report and
chair I believe in addition to council
offices we also have our appointed
Architects present as well
to answer any questions on the design of
the scheme
as members will be aware in the summer
of last year the council approved the
initial business case for this project
uh in the months since extensive work
has been carried out to design the
scheme engage engage with key
stakeholders and partners and consultant
the local residents including at our
well-attended what next for stowmarket
event in September
as you'll see from the report the design
freeze has now been reached with some
changes to what was originally proposed
but again this has been done with
extensive engagement throughout based on
the advice and guidance of the relevant
professional bodies both national and
local
feedback about the scheme has been
overwhelmingly positive and I would once
again like to reiterate how truly and
exciting opportunity this is both for
Stone Market but also for mid-suffic
more broadly
today and by full council at the end of
the month we are anticipating that we
can obtain planning permission by June
or July
a final business case coming back to the
council later this year to include a
detailed funding strategy
the ask of cabinet today is therefore to
approve 250 000 pounds from our growth
and efficiency fund to progress this
scheme to the planning to the planning
phase and to note the key Milestones
that I've just referenced
my thanks is always my scared to
officers in the economic growth team who
have worked very hard across numerous
different work streams over the last few
months and it is to their credit that
such a tremendous scheme is now making
significant Headway and my thanks also
to the various partners and stakeholders
who've been involved with this project
to date
I'm therefore delighted to propose
recommendations 3.1 3.2 3.3 and 3.4 in
the report and I will ask for a second
thank you chair
thank you and a second councilor
Whitehead
yeah I'm very happy to
second this report I think get it's
ambitious it's expensive but it is the
most uh you know looking at the plans it
will be the most wonderful
um facility that we can bring to the
greater stowmarket area to the various
sports clubs involved and particularly
to the high school and the primary
schools creating you know most excellent
um
cricket and rugby facilities and you
know to quote the report for the school
to access to athletic facilities a new
Sports Hall an old weather football
pitch improve multi-games area and and
said the cricket and rugby facilities
um would
create the highest quality sports that
is in the district so I'm very pleased
to see this going forward
thank you very much
do we have any questions from the
cabinet
do we have any questions from anybody
else councilor
thank you chair
um yeah I welcome this project there's
been a lot of work done on it and yeah
I'm really pleased to see it going
forward mid-suffolk needs a high quality
facility like this my one concern all
along has been about
sustainable transport to the site could
I just ask that whilst developing the
business case will there also be
discussions with relevant parties about
providing transport in a sustainable
fashion to and from the side
cancel my juicy
thank you very much chair um
the short answer that question is yes
um I think obviously that's something
that we can look at as part of a uh the
actual planning application itself as
when it progresses to that stage I I do
have a feeling that some of those
discussions may have already started
um but I'm just going to hand over to
officers just to confirm the detail of
that because I'm not uh best place to
answer that
yeah we started on a sustainable travel
strategy for the scheme already we've
been working with the partners to see
what they currently have including bus
routes pedestrian and cycleways as well
as then improving those solicitors to
that site
increasing the frequency of the buses as
well and looking at trial and Pilots we
can do with some funding that's
available
I was just saying you might use electric
buses
um
that's not a question I question
paragraph four five on page 118
just the the last sentence is both
Services provide an all-weather
alternative for training when outdoor
surfaces are unplayable
I sort of understood the 3G and 4G
pitches are still Outdoors am I wrong
all weather
so as we grasp the surfaces
sorry that perhaps
and it sort of means when grass pictures
are not in a condition to be used
perhaps in winter time
any more questions
apologies Council which is
taking it upon myself to answer your
questions
no more questions that anybody wish to
debate this
no
okay so the recommendations are the
cabinet notes the work and progress made
on the scheme to date including
extensive public engagement design and
cost planning and skiing viability
to also note the future gateways for
decision making for the scheme including
bringing the full business case funding
strategy and optimal operating model to
cabinet and Council later this year for
a formal decision
to prove the recommendation to submit a
full planning application and develop
detailed designs for the scheme
and to recommend to council further
spend of 250 000 from the growth and
efficiency fund to enable The Works
outlined in 3.32 progress
so I now ask the officer to conduct the
vote
because of Fleming America
thank you chair that is uh six votes for
that is unanimous
excellent thank you very much everybody
thank you so the next meeting is
scheduled for Monday the 6th of March
and we'll start at 10 30 A.M
meetings closed at 12 16. thank you very
much everybody